let's now jump into understanding
meiosis in some depth so let's start
with the germ cell as we mentioned
already a germ cell is a cell that it
can either go through mitosis to produce
other germ cells or it can undergo
meiosis in order to produce gametes so
this is a germ cell right over here let
me draw the nuclear membrane so that's
the nuclei let me draw the nucleus a
little bit larger just because that's
where where we care a lot about the
chromosomes in it and let me draw a
centrosome which will play a role later
on I want to do that in let's see I'll
do that in this blue color each
centrosome has two centrioles in it but
we'll well I just would clarify some of
the terminology and in the mitosis
videos I focused on a cells of an
organism I just kind of made it up that
had two chromosomes that had a diploid
number of two that had one homologous
pair that had one chromosome from each
of its parents for this video I'm going
to focus on a species not human beings
that would have 23 pairs or 46
chromosomes I'm going to focus on a
species that has that diploid number is
4 and so let's say it has two
chromosomes from the father let me do
that I'll do that in this orange color
I'll do it in the chromatid of depict
the chromatin state it's kind of unwound
so maybe has a long one from the father
and it has a short one from the father
and then it has homologous chromosomes
from the mother so it would have the
long one from the mother and it would
have the short one the short one from
the mother and just like that and
obviously this is a huge simplification
but hopefully this gets the point across
so here it has a diploid number of
chromosomes so this is let me write this
down
this is diploid diploid diploid number
is equal to we have four chromosomes and
then this thing this germ cell let me
write this down this is a germ cell
right over here it will go through
interphase so let me draw that so it
will go through interphase and we
in which it grows and it can replicate
its DNA and its centrosome and so let me
draw that so after it goes through
interphase I want to use my space
carefully because I have a lot of steps
to go through after it goes through
interphase I am going to have in my
nucleus in my nucleus here my DNA will
have replicated so this long this long
chromosome from my father
it will now all the DNA will have
replicated so it might look something
something like that and it's attached at
a it's attached at a centromere all
these central words at a centromere
right here but I'm still trying to draw
it in kind of the chromatin state it's
actually all spread out it's not bunched
up so you can see it very clearly is
these X's and kind of a in a simple
microscope so it's just replicated and
after replicating it is still one
chromosome it has twice the genetic
material but it is still one chromosome
that one chromosome is now made up of
two sister chromatids two sister
chromatids we talked a lot about that in
the mitosis video but it doesn't hurt to
reinforce because it can get a little
bit confusing and then you have that
shorter that shorter chromosome from the
father and then that also replicates
into two sister chromatids attached at a
centromere so these are still two
chromosomes from the father has twice
the amount of DNA but it's containing
the same information just duplicate
versions of that same information and
the same thing is going to happen from
the from the mother you had that long
chromosome from the mother homologous to
this one right over here it's going to
replicate so it's now going to be two
it's now going to be two sister
chromatids and then you have a short
strand from the mother that was
homologous to this one from your father
and that's also going to replicate and
so it's like that and at the end of
interphase it would actually all be it
would all be spread out once again it
won't be bunched up into these clearly
discernible X's I drew them a little
that way otherwise because you would
have trouble seeing how it replicated
and we also have we also have replicated
our centrosome as we've gone through
interphase now we are ready in fact now
we are ready for either mitosis or
meiosis but as I said the focus of this
video is going to be meiosis so let's
let's do some meiosis so the first phase
so the first several phases we call
meiosis 1 and the beginning of meiosis 1
is prophase 1 so let's see what happens
in prophase 1 so prophase 1 so let me
draw the cell right over here so
prophase prophase 1 a couple of things
happen the nuclear membrane begins to
dissolve this is very similar to
prophase 2 prophase when we were looking
at at mitosis so the nuclear envelope
begins to dissolve these things start to
maybe migrate a little bit so these
characters are starting to go it ends at
the different ends and the DNA starts to
bunch up into kind of its condensed form
so now I can draw it so now I can start
to draw it as proper so this is this is
the one from the father right over here
and this is the one from the mother and
I'm drawing them overlapping on purpose
because something very interesting
happens especially in meiosis so this is
the mother right over here this is let
me see let's all do the centromere in
blue now that's a centromere
that's the centromere now this is the
shorter ones from the father this is
these are the shorter ones from the
mother and actually let me just do draw
them on opposite sides just to show that
they don't have to the ones from the
father aren't always on the left-hand
side so this is the shorter one from the
father it could be all on the left-hand
side but doesn't necessarily have to be
and then this is the shorter one from
the mother and I won't draw these
overlapping although they could have
shorter one from the mother and once
again each of these this is a homologous
pair that's a homologous pair over there
now the DNA has been replicated
so in each each of the chromosomes in
homologous pair you have two sister
chromatids and so in this entire
homologous pair you have four chromatids
and so this is sometimes called a tetrad
so let me just get us give ourselves
some terminology so this right over here
is called a tetrad or often often called
a tetrad now the reason why I drew this
overlapping is when we are in prophase
one in meiosis one let me label this
this is pro prophase one you can get
some genetic recombination some
homologous recombination once again this
is a homologous pair one chromosome from
the father that I've gotten from the
father of the species or this the cell
got from its father cell and one from
the mother and they're homologous and
that they might contain different base
pairs different actual DNA but they code
for the same for the same genes so you
know oversimplification but in this in a
similar place on each of these it might
code for eye color or I don't know
personality and you know nothing is that
simple in or how tall you get and it's
not that simple in DNA but just to give
you just to give you an idea of how it
is and the reason why I overlapped them
like this just to show how the
recombination can occur so actually let
me zoom in so this is the one from the
father
once again señal in the condensed form
this is one chromosome made up of two
sister chromatids right over here and I
drew the centromere not to be confused
with centrosomes that's where they are
those two sister chromatids are attached
and then I will draw draw the homologous
chromosome from the mother so the
homologous chromosome from the mother
just like just like that
Amala guess chromosome from the mother
and the recombination can occur at a
point right over here so after you're
done the recombination this side might
look something more like this so let me
let me draw it let me draw it like this
so they essentially break up and they
swap those
sections is one way to think about it so
this one will now have a little a little
piece a little piece from the mother and
it might code for similar genes but now
contains the mother's genetic
information and then and then this one
over here this one over here will now
have the piece and you could say even
the homologous piece from the father
from the father and let me do the suit
to two centromeres and this is really
interesting this isn't you know all the
time there there could be recombination
and oftentimes it can lead to kind of
non optimal things nonsense code and DNA
and might lead to a on functional
organism but this happens fairly common
in meiosis and it's a way once again to
get more variation we've talked about
sexual reproduction before and sexual
reproduction introduces variation into a
population and this obviously when
different sperms find different eggs
that introduces variation but then even
amongst homologous pairs you can
actually have exchange of exchange
between these chromosomes and that's
interesting because as we mentioned each
of these chromosomes they code for a
bunch of different genes and a gene is
kind of Wilken code for specific or a
set of proteins and so this right over
here let's say and this is I'm going to
what I'm about to say is going to be a
huge oversimplification maybe right over
here you coded for eye color or it was
related to or it helped code for eye
color and that you got that from your
dad and here it helped code for eye
color and you got that from your mom
your mom might have trended you towards
a lighter eye color and your dad might
have trying to do towards a darker eye
color but now the one from your mom is
on this chromosome this gene and then
the one or they're both the same gene
they're just different alleles they're
coding for different variants of that
gene and then the allele from your dad
is over here and once again you know
some people get confused with genes and
chromosomes and all this each of this
these chromosomes contain a bunch of
genes these are very long DNA molecules
these code for a bunch of different
genes so a gene will be will be a little
section of here that could get code for
a particular protein so that's what
happens in prophase one in prophase one
you have this content station of your
chromosomes of your homologous pairs you
have you have you can have this
recombination and it's really
interesting this recombination doesn't
tend to happen at just random points
that would kind of break the Jetta get
genetic genetic information
it tends to happen at fairly clean
points and the places where this breakup
is happening these are called the plural
if you just talk about one point it's a
key asthma or if you're talking about
the plural is chiasmata sounds like it
could be a horror movie so key Ozma key
Ozma and the fact that they happen they
tend to happen fairly cleanly this is
you know once again kind of the beauty
of the universe or at least of biology
is that through billions of years of
evolution these things have have kind of
optimized for more variation to happen
in fairly clean ways so I'm going to
leave this video right there I know I
just got to prophase one but this was a
really really important idea of this
homologous recombination or this
chromosomal crossover that we see right
over here and then from there we can
continue through the rest of meiosis 1
and then meiosis 2